hey everybody michael knowles here host
of the michael knowles
show one thing i know a lot of people
like to do at christmas is take a look
back
you know go back and look at old
scrapbooks and photographs and family
movies
so we're going to do the same thing
we're going to go all the way back to
episode
71 of this show years ago
to the war on christmas a history i know
a lot of conservatives even deny that
the war on christmas exists
all the leftists deny that the war on
christmas exists but
it does so for your delight
for your edification for the cause of
fighting
the war on christmas and defending the
christmas side of that
in which i consider myself a three-star
general
please enjoy this classic episode and
merry christmas to everybody
today i assume the role of candy cane
chomping douglas macarthur in the war on
christmas
does it exist are we winning i will
explain why the war on christmas really
matters
and i will be wearing this helmet the
whole time in case any lefties try to
break in and attack me with euphemistic
language
plus the mailbag i'm michael knowles and
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
is there a war on christmas of course
there's a war on christmas
stop trying to be a cool guy and get the
new york times to like you by pretending
there isn't
there obviously is it's now fashionable
in some conservative circles
where people care what the new york
times thinks to say that the war on
christmas is some crazy illusion
of conservatives and i'm you know i'm
not that kind of conservative no no
i'm educated and fancy and i think wait
wait don't tell me is clever i'm not one
of those
middle state rubes who pays attention to
the degraded culture belched out every
year
by our sophisticated bettors on the
coasts stop it
stop it you're embarrassing yourself of
course there is a war on christmas to
begin here's the first bit of evidence
barack obama struck the word christmas
from the white house christmas card
a quick look back through history shows
this is not the norm
calvin coolidge wrote in his 1927 white
house christmas card
the real spirit of christmas if we think
on these things there will be a
born in us a savior and over us will
shine a star
sending its gleam of hope to the world
fdr wrote some variation of merry
christmas from the president and mrs
roosevelt
each of the 150 years he reigned in the
white house harry truman wrote
quote as 1950 ebbs to its close
our hearts turn once more to bethlehem
and to the coming of a little child
the divine infant that brought love to a
weary world
six paragraphs later six paragraphs
later he concluded quote
glory to god in the highest and on earth
peace
good will peace and goodwill toward men
eisenhower wrote a curt
typical season's greetings for christmas
and new year jfk
happy christmas the pieces of lbj's card
available still don't show the wording
but given his preference for four-letter
epithets that's probably for the best
language on the other cards is hard to
track down as well until we get to
george w bush
who included verses from psalms on the
christmas card
then we get to barack obama who not only
struck mention of christmas entirely
but according to his own white house
social secretary tried to ban
the creche the nativity scene from the
east room of the white house
now why would you do that you ask why
would he want to do that
because they wanted to make christmas
more quote inclusive
that's the line offered by the way
that's how you know that there is a war
on christmas
school districts will replace merry
christmas and happy new year with the
vague
happy holidays retail outlets work
environments christmas parties have
become vague holiday parties
in many circles particularly in the
cultural centers of the country
to say merry christmas has become a
political act
that expresses to the retail worker or
the acquaintance your political and
politically incorrect point of view
and if you harp on this long enough as i
do as i do every year
you will inevitably get the same reply
well
yeah but why shouldn't the greeting be
more inclusive
you know not everybody celebrates
christmas you know and and that's the
moving of the goal posts
first there wasn't a war on christmas
now there is but it doesn't matter
that's how you know the other trick that
those who deny the cultural movement
we'll say
is that it isn't a war the language it's
hyperbolic it's ridiculous there isn't a
war
you don't say there is there aren't guns
that's true there aren't tanks and
bullets
christmas is not literally being cut
down by machine gun fire
that's because the war on christmas is a
figure of speech
much like the war on poverty say poverty
is not being
cut down by bullets because like
christmas it isn't material what is
meant by the quote war on christmas
is a battle of language and culture
there is a belligerent group of
left-wing cultural warriors
which seeks to replace clear traditional
precise language
christmas with vague meaningless
euphemisms
like happy holidays and seasons
greetings
of course both phrases have been around
for a long time but whereas in the past
they referred specifically to christmas
and new years
like eisenhower's christmas card seasons
greetings for christmas and new year
now they serve as a replacement for the
politically correct term
what the modern mind considers the grave
offense of christmas time
merry christmas but aren't there other
major holidays during christmas time
besides christmas and new year's
this is usually what they ask but not
really there are holidays to be sure but
no major ones
the closest contender we have is
hanukkah which is the jewish festival of
lights
but while hanukkah is indeed an ancient
holiday it dates back about 2000 years
it is a relatively minor holiday major
jewish holidays are biblical they
feature restrictions on work
because hanukkah is non-biblical there
are few religious restrictions on work
according to historian diane ashton
hanukkah rose to prominence in america
as it did
not in the rest of the world because of
two reformed rabbis in 19th century
cincinnati
who worried their children had a little
connection to the synagogue
before that there is little record of
hanukkah celebrations
the rabbis modeled the celebration in
gift-giving after christmas
as ashton explains quote they didn't see
christmas as something they could do
easily because it's christian
but they did want to do something like
that because it was american
so kosher restaurants even started
serving turkey dinners after the
american custom
that's hanukkah the far less credible
pretender is kwanzaa
which is a socialist contrivance
invented by a criminal la city college
africana studies professor
named milana karenga in 1966. he created
kwanzaa to be a holiday specifically for
black americans
even though black americans already
celebrated christmas ironically
while virtually all african slaves were
brought to america from the west coast
of africa
kwanzaa is a swahili word meaning first
fruits that originated in east africa
which means none of the slaves brought
to america would have understood it
now one of the seven principles of
kwanzaa is communism
ujamaa cooperative economics and
melania karenga himself was sentenced to
prison in 1971
for felonious assault and false
imprisonment after he sexually assaulted
and tortured multiple women
as the la times reported he ordered them
to strip naked whipped them with an
electrical cord and beat them with a
karate baton
karenga then placed a hot soldering iron
in one woman's mouth and against her
face
and tightened her big toe in a vice he
finally put detergent and running hoses
in their mouths and hit them on the head
with toasters
as the black power movement of the 1970s
has waned
so too has the celebration of the
holiday on the high end of estimates
0.3 percent of americans acknowledge the
supposed holiday
that rate continues to decline so why
pretend christmas time does not center
around christmas
why pretend there are so many other
major holidays on equal footing
there's new year on january 1st and
we've long said
good tiding for christmas and a happy
new year there's hanukkah a relatively
minor holiday
but by the way we don't say happy
holidays instead of happy labor day
even though rosh hashanah which is a far
more important jewish holiday than
hanukkah
sometimes occurs around the same time
you don't say that we don't say happy
holidays
or seasons greetings instead of happy
columbus day
even though yom kippur another much more
important jewish holiday
sometimes occurs around that time well
actually now we don't say
happy columbus day either we say blessed
indigenous peoples day or something like
that
that's another story there is kwanzaa a
virtually non-existent holiday what else
is there there's boxing day in which no
one in the united states celebrates
there's the winter solstice which people
pretend is a thing but nobody celebrates
and of course it isn't about the the
celebrants of hanukkah or kwanzaa
or the winter solstice who are waging
the war on christmas
it's the atheist left who constantly
seeks to replace clear
vivid language with bizarre secular
euphemisms
this is the essence of political
correctness that the essence of
political correctness is to replace
clear language
with euphemisms to remove the strength
of that language
so we have abortion abortion isn't the
killing of babies in the womb
it's women's reproductive health
assisted suicide isn't
killing the old and the sick it's
euthanasia euthanasia is a word that
literally means
good death the good day you know it's
good it's nice so it's no
surprise that his political correctness
reached peak potency in the late 1990s
and early 2000s
we see the war on christmas denver
banned religious floats from its
christmas parade
new york mayor mike bloomberg displayed
the city's holiday tree
major department stores like macy's
removed references to christmas
public schools began removing christian
symbols from christmas time display
all around this time how coincidental
now the left alternately denies that the
war on christmas exists
and then when they can't deny it any
longer they say it doesn't matter who
cares who cares
it's just language you're just arguing
over semantics
sure but semantics means meaning if the
language doesn't matter then why are the
war on christmas belligerence so
insistent
on changing the traditional clear and
precise language
if it doesn't matter then great great
that's fat perfect
merry christmas and happy new year
forget about happy holidays but of
course language matters
of course those who insist on the
bizarre vague euphemisms they know
precisely that
because politics sits downstream of
culture
you know who else knows that as
president trump here he is on the
campaign trail
you know we're getting near that
beautiful christmas season that people
don't talk about
anymore they don't use the word
christmas because it's not
politically correct you go department
stores and they'll say
happy new year and they'll say other
things and it'll be red they'll have it
painted but they don't say well guess
what
we're saying merry christmas again
[Applause]
this was a great promise people didn't
really take it seriously because they
don't take these language issues
seriously
but here is president trump as a
president
the christmas story begins 2000 years
ago with a mother
a father their baby son and the most
extraordinary gift of all
the gift of god's love for all of
humanity
whatever our beliefs we know that the
birth of jesus christ
and the story of this incredible life
forever changed the course of human
history
each and every year at christmas time we
recognize
that the real spirit of christmas is not
what we have it's about who we are
each one of us is a child
of god that is the true source of joy
this time of the year that is what makes
every christmas merry and now as the
president of the united states
it's my tremendous honor to finally wish
america
and the world a very merry
christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
there's nothing like just sitting here
with a little candy cane pipe and
watching that that is pretty good and
there's good news the great news
in the war on christmas is that clear
language and tradition are finally
winning after a decade or a decade and a
half
according to a 2005 gallup poll 41
percent of respondents
deferred to happy holidays over merry
christmas ten years later a similar
survey albeit through a different
research center
found that number had dropped to just 25
percent
now the last two years have brought a
cultural exuberance to the right
and it's given us myriad early christmas
presents got tax reform
originalist judges responsible foreign
policy massive deregulation
obamacare mandate repeal the list goes
on and on
now all of this has been possible
because of a cultural shift in the
country
away from insidious euphemisms and
political correctness
the the pinnacle of insidious euphemisms
now is not the time to retreat or seek
the approval of the new york times
david mccullough observed that to write
well is to think clearly
and that's why it's so hard don't give
in to fashionably muddled thinking
especially around the incarnation of the
divine logic
himself i'm going to put down my candy
cane pipe and we're going to get into
the mailbag first question from david
hi michael first i'd like to point out
i'm a big fan of your show thanks
you had made an argument for venerating
mary i understand
having great respect to mary as the
woman chosen by god to bear jesus in
human form
but i'm curious as to how does praying
to mary not conflict with the first two
commandments i myself am a christian and
base my faith on scripture
and use scripture as the basis to
evaluate practices ideologies etc thanks
david
a good time of year to be asking that
question um
you know i think a lot of this boils
down to this question that some
protestants ask which is
why would you pray to anybody why not
just pray directly to jesus why would
you pray
to saints or why would you have people
on earth pray pray to you
in revelation uh chapter five here's a
verse
and when he had taken it the four living
creatures and the 24 elders fell down
before the lamb
each one had a harp and they were
holding golden bowls full of
incense which are the prayers of god's
people
so we have the saints offering prayers
to god in heaven
they're offering prayers for what
they're not offering prayers for
themselves they're in heaven
they're offering prayers for other
people so as
early as the first century of the
christian tradition we see
people uh asking for intercession
praying
for intercession and we we have the city
of god the saints who are in heaven
praying for those of us who are aren't
there yet or who need our
their prayers we have first timothy from
paul which is pseudepigraphical
but it might tell you something
certainly we still read first timothy
quote
first of all then i urge that
supplications prayers intercessions
and thanksgiving be made for all men for
kings and all who are in high positions
that we may lead a quiet and peaceable
life godly and respectful in every way
this is good and pleasing to god our
savior who desires all men to be saved
and to come to the knowledge of the
truth
now paul asks others to pray for him all
the time
in romans in ephesians colossians that
first thessalonians 2 thessalonians
and he prayed for others we see that in
second thessalonians christ himself
tells us to pray for others he says
quote love your enemies and
pray for those who persecute you why why
wouldn't he tell them i'll just have
them pray to me directly
no he says you have to pray for others
pray to whom pray to him
jesus regularly supplies for one person
based on the faith of another person
so in matthew we see christ says oh
woman great is your faith
be it done for you as you desire and her
daughter is healed
so it's not the daughter praying it's
someone interceding for the daughter and
praying and
based on the woman's faith the daughter
the daughter is healed we don't hear
about the daughter's faith we only hear
about the mother's faith
matthew you know another in matthew lord
have mercy on my son for he has seizures
and he suffers terribly
in mark teacher i brought my son to you
that he has a spirit that makes him mute
in luke do not fear only believe and she
your daughter
will be well so one thing we also know
from james is that the prayers of the
righteous work especially well
so james says the prayer of a righteous
man has great power in its effects
we know that mary is quite righteous she
there's the immaculate conception she
was
selected to be the ark of the new
covenant to give
birth to to the incarnation to our risen
lord
seems to me she would be a good person
to to pray for you as well
uh i think that's a lot of words i think
probably you could answer that question
by saying she's the mother of jesus
she's the mother of god but uh that i
hope that clears it up a little bit
because very often
i think people say well i don't think we
should do these rituals or these
traditions or have this liturgy
because it's not in scripture but
actually it isn't scripture it does come
from scripture the liturgy comes from
scripture
and you just have to read a little more
uh more broadly or more
closely to see exactly how that fits in
it's not always clear to people who
aren't in the tradition itself
next question from bridget hey michael
so i've made a bit of a political come
around in 2016 due to all the election
craziness
i was pretty far to the left in most
ways and still am on a lot of economical
issues
but i've recently become more devout in
my catholic faith and have changed my
position
from pro-choice to pro-life i'm afraid
to tell my pro-choice friends and family
because i'm afraid they'll ostracize me
and i was wondering if you have any
advice
i do this is hard this is a hard thing
happened to me i was pro-choice back
when i was
i wasn't really left-wing but i was
pro-choice i'm from new york
new york republicans aren't just not
terribly conservative
as i got more conservative it was clear
to me that
abortion isn't good and we shouldn't
have have it be a legal thing
diana schaab who's a bioethicist
convinced me of this over a lunch
and when it happened i didn't know how
to tell my friends um
the way you have to do it is two things
unapologetically and patiently
don't apologize the left sees pro-life
as anti-woman
they really earnestly believe that it's
not just some joke and
uh so you you have to be unapologetic
you have nothing to apologize
for but you also have to
be patient with them they're not going
to understand be calm
usually the first person to get angry
and start screaming in an argument
is the one who doesn't understand really
what you're arguing over
so be patient be calm about it and uh
you know louis c.k had a good bid on
this
louis ck that now disgraced comedian but
he had a good bit he said
you know abortion i don't think it's a
big deal it's like going to the bathroom
it's just going to the bathroom it's not
a big deal
or it's killing a baby it's it's either
completely meaningless like excretion or
it's murdering a baby and i think you
have to explain
those premises because if you explain
those premises and it's perfectly
logical and compassionate from there
and then you just debate the premise is
this
baby in the womb is it is it living
yes is it human yeah it's not a dog it's
not a giraffe it's human
so it's a is it independent or is it
part of the mother it's independent it
has its own genome
it will develop into its own personality
it has a beating heart within not very
many days
it's obviously independent uh or
separate rather it's obviously dependent
for food on
on its mother and so if all of those
things are true then the question is
are you willing to risk what what is the
moral equivalent of murder
because you on the premise that it
doesn't yet have human dignity when
you're going to abort it
if you put it in those terms i think you
might not bring them
totally to understanding but they'll
begin to understand the premise
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts